days later sadri asani still can't
believe what happened the house he lived
in with his family now lies in ruins
welcome Oh doctor cause I'm oh boy where
in the world can such a thing happen but
I oh boy it's a disaster well something
like that might happen in Israel or in
Gaza I've seen images like that on TV
Bill Tom oh there's nothing more I can
say you can see the damage what more is
there to say the shooting started in the
middle of the night according to the
government the attack was carried out by
an albanian terror group
but in this neighborhood mainly
inhabited by ethnic Albanians people are
baffled they have no idea why they were
targeted the attack left 18 people dead
10 of them fighters and eight policemen
the shooting continued for several hours
large parts of the neighborhood were
reduced to rubble residents are still in
shock many of them hold the government
responsible fighter Raja Vidya just come
on move the government's fault they knew
about it and did nothing what a mere
paas d we had no idea if we'd known we
wouldn't have stayed do you know the
trauma my wife and I are going through
we're constantly on medication
she's got the method do you know how
scary it is to be shot at even once
Joseph just they were shooting the whole
time you've ever been how could dozens
of heavily-armed fighters enter a
residential area unnoticed that's the
question everyone in Macedonia is asking
there are plenty of theories local
resident Latimer pivovar off is the
former head of the country's military
intelligence agency he considers it
highly unlikely that the authorities
knew nothing monash team logo bit nosey
then this is supposed to have been a
terror attack but no terror group can
achieve its goal without backing from
the local population you're posting this
word that SIL du cuckoo nema pogiren
kumanovo there's no support for such a
thing varanasi lokesh dismiss seiga kaku
yeshivah absolute no Neiman Nick I live
in this area the relationships between
ethnic groups are extremely good cinema
novo visa renewal could the government
have known about the attack before it
happened muhammad zakir ahead of the
mainly Albanian language broadcaster
lsat believes it did he's one of the
most prominent voices speaking out in
favor of equality between macedonians
and Albanians well sister toaster nobody
wanted to see what happened in kumanovo
apart from groove skis government
tribunal scooch adorable they wanted to
distract the public in order to spread
panic and fear punica stuff nobody
believed such a thing could happen near
the commercial what commercial alluded
that view is shared by many here in
kumanovo over the last few months
revelations of corruption and abuse of
power within Prime Minister Nicola
groove skis government have been part of
the daily order it's coming under
increasing pressure and public anger is
mounting do I wanna need this money boom
tomorrow this was a major event designed
to distract people from the spying
scandal team and all the other
revelations pamir mushroom turbo
put it about cynical my next-door
neighbors are O'Banion's we get on great
we visit one another we're friends we
can't allow this way of life to be
destroyed after you feel some old bunker
I'm Albanian he's Macedonian people shop
at both our stools we ordinary people
live together normally that'll be a
hundred dinner will develop many
Macedonians are struggling to make ends
meet the country is one of the poorest
in Europe unemployment is high a group
of schoolchildren has come to lay
flowers in the ruined neighborhood any
attempt to divide ethnic groups here has
failed macedonians and Albanians are
more United than ever this time against
the government